well meanwhile Russia's prime minister
Mikhail mishustan is due to meet China's
president Xi Jinping it's part of a
two-day visit to Beijing the two Nations
have ramped up economic and diplomatic
cooperation with tires growing closer
since moscow's invasion of Ukraine well
let's bring in Katrina you she's across
this forest in Beijing Katrina I believe
that meeting is due to have in any
minute now it's a real reflection of how
friendly things have become
that's right so mechanics Houston
arrived in Beijing earlier today on
Wednesday he was certainly greeted like
an old friend even though this is his
first time in China as Russia's prime
minister he met earlier today with
Premier Lee Chung and other Chinese
officials and he's due to me very
shortly with Xi Jinping now president XI
sees Russia's friendship and partnership
as very important strategically as he
describes it China's locked in an
ideological battle with the west and he
needs Putin's support because of that
and partly because of this we've seen
mishustan while he's been here say that
china-russia ties are at unprecedented
levels now he's here of course to deepen
economic cooperation with Beijing and
earlier today with Chinese officials he
signed some agreements extending
cooperation in Trade Services
Agriculture and in sport and yesterday
in a forum for businessmen in Shanghai
he said that trade between the two
countries had the potential of reaching
200 billion dollars this year and if so
that would be up from 73 billion dollars
in 20 22 now China benefits immensely
from this relationship because the West
has shunned Russia and Russian firms
it's now very reliant on China and China
gets many benefits among them cheap oil
and gas and Russia has also agreed to
conduct many of its transactions now in
Chinese New Year and that's the Chinese
currency but of course this is not just
about Chinese benefits Beijing is also
seeing this as a partly liability
because it's close ties with Moscow
means that its reputation in Europe
particularly has also been damaged well
speaking of that reputation Katrina I
wonder what's happening with beijing's
peace plan for Ukraine it feels like
they've been on that real diplomatic
charm offensive in the last few weeks
[Applause]
that's right so it's special Envoy for
Eurasian Affairs leeway has been sent to
Europe partly on an image damage control
tour I think but Beijing is selling this
as a peace Mission he's in the past week
meant uh went to Ukraine Poland and
France and he's also met with EU
officials and Beijing is really at pains
to say that China here is an honest
broker it wants to sue for peace it's a
neutral party in this conflict but of
course that neutrality has been
repeatedly questioned by the US and its
allies and if anything this Mission this
peace Mission by leeway is also being
described as Mission Impossible because
what China wants is the status quo in
Russia to be maintained and for
President Vladimir Putin's power to be
protected and they want a ceasefire
under those terms and of course Kiev has
told Beijing over and over again that it
will not accept any agreement which
involves steeding territory to Russia
Katrina are you there across that visit
for us in the Chinese Capital Beijing
thank you Katrina